Mandy Moore receives her star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame I have such an
appreciation and fondness and respect
from my young self because she is what
brought me here to this moment today 20
years later with her own star on the
Walk of Fame the 34 year old actress
accepted the big honor on Monday in Los
Angeles and was supported by her
longtime friend and a walk to remember
love interest
Shan West who gave us all the fields
with his speech not only was his film a
wonderful experience in every way it
also gave me the chance to fall for this
fantastic woman Mandy you're an absolute
gem but you're about to be immortalized
in Hollywood in general I couldn't be
more proud of you I couldn't be more
happy for you
Mandy's hubby Taylor goldsmith and her
on screen and this is us husband and
co-stars were also in attendance I'm
always there to support my girl all the
time so but it's a no it's a proud
moment you know to be remembered in
stone and brass among so many great and
talented artists NDT spoke with the
actress after her big moment a milestone
a Hollywood Walk of Fame star how does
this feel surreal this is not something
that typically happened it's just
somebody like me I'm trying to be
present and be in the moment and
appreciate it and not feel super
overwhelmed but it's very overwhelming
well this is us family the walk to
remember fam how did that feel to have
all that support incredible it's crazy
I've been in this business now for 20
years and I feel like those two projects
in particular really signify like just
monumental moments in my career starting
with a walk to remember and now with
this is us and to have both Shane from
the movie and then my whole this is us
family here just means more than
anything you know I mean you've had a
pretty major year getting married and
then you've got as you said love of your
life Taylor here supporting you is that
emotional how does it make you feel to
kind of look at where your life's at
right now and with him looking up at you
immense gratitude immense gratitude I
feel incredibly lucky to sort of be at
this juncture of my life and
to sort of feel like I'm coming into my
own understanding Who I am
owning my power and yeah to have the
people I love the most by my side just
as it means the most and a quick
reaction to Dan speaks singing candy
it's like candy I can feel it when you
walk even when you talk it takes over me
you're so dandy I want it I want to know
can you feel it too just like I do
that was something I never thought that
I would hear I mean the fact that Dan of
the the man of many words like referred
back to these awful lyrics I can say
that because I didn't write them
the nonsensical lyrics I should say is
truly remarkable
[Music]